Aaron is with us in Columbus Ohio hey
Aaron
Happy New Year hey hey Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up so my
wife is and her family have been on the
Ramsey plan for a while which is why
when we got married seven months ago she
came in with no student loans I wish I
could say the same for myself I have
approximately 73,000 in student loans
and I know that you are not a fan of the
public service loan forgiveness program
I'm about three years into that program
and we have 55 in cash 55 thousand in
cash and we have about 92 thousand total
just wanted to get your thoughts on what
we should do moving forward website
92,000 in total what with our retirement
and Roth oh okay okay
and so not counting not counting
retirement all you could get your hands
on would be 55 correct you don't have
any investments that are not in
retirement I believe we have a few
investments but not too many okay all
right
which would add to the 55 figure then
okay yeah and you have $70,000 seventy
two thousand dollars in student loan
debt what other debts do you guys have
that is our only debt and so I guess my
concern would be you know if I continue
doing the public service
you know I potentially save $50,000 and
your household income is what currently
90 but my wife will be returning to
school in the fall to get her MBA from
Ohio State and how are we paying for
that we well as a staff member at OSU I
get half off tuition for her and she's
on track to potentially get a full ride
okay all right good
all right so we have to pay cash for it
you understand
that you have to pay for this education
right yes and that's why we're we're
thinking of we don't want to take out
any more loans for her right we have to
first make sure that we don't borrow any
more that's rule number one of getting
out of that yeah a real number right now
the student loan forgiveness program the
problem with it is twofold one it is 10
years of hostage your hostage to this
thing for 10 years there are some
student loan forgiveness programs that
are 3 years and some that are even 5
years and they give away a fifth a year
or 1/3 a year and the in the underserved
areas and those are fine the 10 year is
just too long for you to be a hostage
number one number two it's not working
the first articles that came out 10
15,000 people applied 96 were granted I
read an article over the holidays so far
only 206 people have been given this
forgiveness 206 people out of millions
and so I don't like these odds the
government is screwing you is what it is
and so no I paid that off as soon as you
possibly can now we've got to have the
money for the NBA so we need to make
sure we exactly what we're getting into
there and so you may want to hold off
just a little bit on paying it down but
once you figure out she's got a free
ride that 55,000 goes at this thing and
then you knock out that other 7,000 or
17,000 as fast as you possibly can get
yourself out of debt because it's not
working man I mean you don't want to be
one of the millions of people that apply
for this and 206 people get it that's
called dashing your hopes on the rocks
right that's what you know it's almost
like playing the lottery right there
so no thank you no thank you and no
thank you for seven more years of
student loans hanging around Sallie Mae
hanging around your house Oh ugly woman
get her out of your house